hey 42 here 40% of the human race did
not survive beyond this first birthday
welcome to RIT the word time is the most
commonly used now in the English
language the human heart pumped enough
blood in a lifetime to fill three
supertankers the dialling code for
Russia is double-oh-seven
in 2008 a man in Ohio was arrested for
having sex with a picnic table the Nazis
made it illegal on pain of death for
Apes to give the Heil Hitler salute in
Japan only 2% of adoptions are children
98% are adult males aged between 25 to
30 Liechtenstein the world's six
smallest country is the world's largest
exporter of false teeth ten percent of
all the photographs in the world were
taken in the past 12 months British
spies used to use semen as invisible ink
but they stopped because it began to
smell when it wasn't fresh in the 12th
century the danish army consisted of
seven men the ancient Romans discovered
parrots could speak and so taught them
to say Hail Caesar
but when they got bored with this they
talked to eating them instead thanks for
the view subscribe for more 42
you